Forget about exoplanets -- there could be
exoMOONS with liquid oceans.
Maybe even alien jellyfish!
Hello, I'm Ian O'Neill, Space Producer for
DiscoveryNews.com, and I'm commandeering the
DNews studio to talk a little about aliens...
or more specifically, potential alien worlds
that could support life.
You may have heard all the kerfuffle about
Kepler-186f.
This Earth-sized exoplanet was discovered
orbiting its red dwarf star within the habitable
zone.
This is exciting because IF the exoplanet
is rocky and IF it has water, there's a good
chance that its atmosphere could keep the
water in a liquid state AND possibly support
life.
This is the first Earth-sized exoplanet discovered
inside a star's habitable zone!
Awesome, awesome, awesome discovery!
Kepler-186f was detected by NASA's Kepler
Space Telescope, but it's not really a discovery
of a "second Earth" -- we simply do not know
if that world is as barren and cold as Mars
or a broiling hellhole like Venus, two worlds,
by the way, that orbit the sun in its habitable
zone, but are FAR from being habitable.
So, for me, there's another really cool possibility
for potential life-giving worlds out there
in the galaxy other than looking for habitable
exoplanets, and it doesn't depend on how far
away from the heat of their star they are.
Remember the world of Pandora in the epic
movie Avatar?
Well, that wasn't an exoplanet, it was in
fact a moon orbiting a massive exoplanet.
These moons are what astronomers call "exomoons."
Our solar system has some fascinating moons
orbiting Jupiter and Saturn that, may not
look like the science fiction rainforest moon
of Pandora, but they do have vast sub-surface
oceans beneath their frozen crusts -- the
water is heated to a liquid by tidal forces
squeezing the insides of the moon creating
a heat source -- no sunlight required!
Jupiter's moon Europa, for example, has an
ocean and some astrobiologists think that
the environment is ideal for not only microbial
life to thrive, but complex organisms may
be evolving there.
If you've seen the movie Europa Report, you'll
know what I mean.
If you haven't seen it, I won't spoil the
ending.
Promise.
Also, most recently, it was revealed that
Saturn's moon Enceladus also has a subsurface
ocean and its internal tidal heating drives
the dinky world's famous water plumes, so
there could be some kind of cosy life-giving
environment there too.
Earlier this month, astronomers made the first
ever detection of a moon in orbit around an
exoplanet.
They discovered it using the cool method of
"microlensing" -- that's when a planet or
star passes in front of a distant star, briefly
amplifying the starlight.
Astronomers saw a little bump next to the
lightcurve of the microlensing event.
They believe that this bump is the first direct
observation of a moon in orbit around an exoplanet.
Although there was little doubt that exomoons
do exist, it's always awesome to get some
observational evidence.
There's no word about whether or not this
exomoon has any habitable qualities like Europa
or Enceladus, but I can't help but wonder
about what may appear to be frozen exomoons
that actually have hidden oceans containing
life.
Time to launch some ice drills to Europa,
for, you know, research.
Just don't take a swim.
Does this get you excited for the next exomoon
discovery?
Tell us in the comments below, and don't forget
to subscribe for more DNews.